being seemed to be heating up in Prince  Harry's love life the 32 year old royal  is reportedly dating actress Megan Marco  who is best known for her role as Rachel  Zane on Seuss it's my job to help you  not the other way around according to  the UK's Sunday Express the Prince of  Wales is falling for the American  actress a source claims the two are  enjoying each other's company and  there's definite chemistry between them  I might want to come there earlier this  week the suit star fuelled romance  rumors when she instagrammed a throwback  of a solo trip to England wearing a  bracelet similar to one worn by Harry  this caused many to speculate the Royal  gave her the accessory as a gift  Kensington Palace declined to comment on  Harry's personal life et has also  reached out to Megan's reps  you